l'innovation dans le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire est quelque chose de
passionnant
en effet on est tous impliqués dans
notre alimentation
on aime tous on a tous une madeleine de
proust on aime tous partagé un repas
avec des amis
l'alimentation est quelque chose de très
personnel est la fois c'est quelque
chose de très social c'est le partage le
plaisir c'est la convivialité
mais c'est aussi un sujet très important
à pau a étudié car on sait le lien entre
notre alimentation et notre santé et on
sait aussi les problématiques de
développement durable et environnemental
autour de notre alimentation
avec la perspective de pouvoir nourrir
le monde c'est population qui est en
constante croissance mais aussi de
pouvoir mieux la nourrir mieux la
nourrir d'un point de vue nutritionnel
d'un point de vue développement durable
d'un point de vue éthique mais aussi
éviter les gaspillages l'industrie
agroalimentaire éthique brillante dans
l'optimisation de ses procédés et de ses
produits
mais aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
multitude de produits de plus en plus
complexes mais à la fois qu'ils ont un
goût et une qualité de plus en plus
standardisés de plus ces produits sont
très difficiles à décrypter d'un point
de vue nutritionnel et le consommateur a
du mal à faire un choix judicieux par
rapport à son alimentation
si l'on veut vraiment forcer le trait
notre surréaliste national rené magritte
dirais ceci n'est pas une pizza je ne
lui donne pas tort puisque elle ne
contient plus de fromage puis de l'olive
et seulement quelques pourcents de
thomas alors pourquoi en est on arrivé
là
est ce le besoin de d'optimiser notre
chaîne alimentaire
est ce le fait que l'on n'est plus
éduqués par rapport à notre nutrition et
par rapport à ce que l'on mange
est ce également le fait de ne plus de
ne plus parler de l'alimentation
dans les écoles ou simplement la
praticité autour de nos produits ou
aussi parce que le budget alloué à notre
alimentation est en constante baisse
pour pouvoir relever le défi de nourrir
le monde et de le nourrir mieux il va
falloir faire une révolution
il va falloir changer le cadre il va
falloir manger différemment il va
falloir produire différemment et en
général dans l'histoire on voit que
toute révolution vient du peuple
est ce que vous vous souvenez du fameux
replicator de star trek
ce magnifique appareil qui permet de
construire un aliment par le
réarrangement sub moléculaire est ce
qu'on en est arrivé là
est ce que c'est ça le futur de notre
alimentation cette machine qui
dématérialise nos aliments et qui fait
fi de la qualité des produits du terroir
de la passion que l'on peut mettre à
cuisiner
eh bien non moi je refuse de me limiter
intel futures et au sein de notre
laboratoire osmar gastronomie lab on
observe tous les jours les nouveaux
produits les nouvelles tendances en
matière d'alimentation et aujourd'hui
j'aimerais bien vous présenter ma miss
mama vision ma vision moonshot de
l'avenir de notre alimentation
et c'est à venir de notre alimentation
je le bats sur deux acteurs clés le
premier acteur ce sont les nouvelles
technologies et notamment les
technologies du digital qui aujourd'hui
font vraiment partie de notre vie
quotidienne et ensuite aussi les
nouvelles biotechnologies ces nouvelles
biotechnologies vont nous permettre de
produire différemment mais aussi d'avoir
accès à de nouvelles ressources
le deuxième acteur important de ce futur
c'est le consommateur c'est vous c'est
moi c'est l'artisan c'est le chef c'est
le producteur et je pense que
l'innovation ne sera plus de
l'innovation pour le consommateur mais
de l'innovation par le consommateur et
on va devoir changer notre façon
gérer l'innovation on va devoir intégrer
cette ce consommateur cet utilisateur au
centre de la démarche en faisant du prof
funding du crowdsourcing en faisant de
l'innovation qui est centrée sur sept
utilisateurs en tenant compte aussi de
l'expérience utilisateur en prenant
l'économie du partage en prenant
l'innovation ouverte et en créant des
communautés d'utilisateurs qui partagent
leur passion et toutes ces concepts sont
aujourd'hui utilisés dans des nouvelles
sortes dans des nouvelles structures
d'innovation que sont les lignes lab
nous allons donc tous devenir des
consom'acteurs et des consommateurs
producteurs et ici les nouvelles
technologies ne vont pas dénaturer nos
aliments mais vont plutôt nous aider à
nous réapproprier notre alimentation
faire des meilleurs choix
avoir un meilleur esprit critique sur
nos choix mais aussi faciliter l'accès à
des ingrédients de qualité ou encore
améliorer nos techniques culinaires et
tout ça fait écho avec la révolution des
make-up savez les make her say des gens
qui créent des nouveaux objets qu'ils
inventent des nouvelles technologies
dans les fab lab et bien moi je prédis
que tout ne cuisinent vont devenir des
fab lab on va recommencer à cuisiner
comme nos grands mères mais en août il y
en utilisant les nouvelles technologies
nous allons donc devenir des
consommateurs producteurs nous allons
produire une partie de notre
alimentation chez soi au travail lors
des pauses et midi dans des jardins
partagés ou encore directement dans
notre cuisine en utilisant l'hydroponie
la cua pony et en développant
l'agriculture urbaine
nous allons avoir accès à de nouveaux
ingrédients comme les insectes comme les
micro algues aux mimiques aux protéines
et ses ingrédients vont se retrouver à
part entière dans notre alimentation
comme à l'époque de nos grands parents
on a découvert les pâtes alimentaires
qui se sont mis naturellement à côté des
tno sacro-sainte pommes de terre nous
allons aussi avoir une alimentation qui
est plus personnalisé en fonction d'eux
besoins et en fonction de nos envies en
effet certaines technologies comme le
coin de tifa itself nous permet de
mesurer en permanence nos données
biométriques
c'est à dire nos besoins alimentaires ou
nos carences en aliments s'il on le met
en parallèle avec les scanners
alimentaire qui permettent de déterminer
la composition d'un produit qui est dans
votre assiette et quitte le transmet
directement à votre smartphone une
application de votre smartphone va vous
expliquer d'un point de vue nutritionnel
quel est l'impact de cette composition
et à ce moment là vous allez avoir le
libre arbitre de pouvoir choisir si ce
produit alimentaire est assez équilibré
pour votre régime ou si vous préférez
privilégier le plaisir de manger cet
aliment et toutes ces données par
rapport à la composition de nos aliments
ou aussi forcé les industriels à
produire des produits agroalimentaires
qui sont plus équilibrés qu'ils sont
plus intéressants d'un point de vue
nutritionnel
il y aura également si ces couteaux qui
permettent de déterminer l'état de
fraîcheur de vos aliments et je prédis
que dans le futur les ingrédients sentez
que vous mangez aujourd'hui sous forme
de médicaments vont se retrouver dans
votre épicerie dans votre cuisine et
vous allez rajouter un peu d'anti
oxydants par ci un peu de prébiotiques
ou un peu d'oméga 3 dans vos recettes de
tous les jours ces nouvelles
technologies vont nous permettre aussi
de mieux distribuer avoir un accès
facilité par exemple aux circuits courts
ou imaginer des plateformes où certaines
personnes voudraient manger des produits
faits maison et d'autres auraient
préparé des produits en trop grande
quantité et donnerait ses produits aux
personnes qui veulent manger des
produits faits maison
les outils de la cuisine intelligente
vont s'ils nous permettre d'améliorer
nos pratiques dans la cuisine mais aussi
d'éviter le gaspillage
par exemple un frigo intelligent vous
dirai attention vos tomates arrive à
leur date de péremption
mais vous avez également des poivrons et
des filets de poulet dont je vous
propose un petit poulet basquaise
directement il contacte votre four qui
se met en face de préchauffage et vous
allez avoir votre recette sous votre
plan de travail pas à pas pour réaliser
votre poulet
cet autre cuisine ici en dessous intègre
des tiroirs dans laquelle vous pouvez
cultiver des micro algues ou des herbes
alimentaire et intègre un système
complet qui permet de la gestion de vos
déchets ménagers cela va également ces
nouvelles technologies améliorer nos
pratiques dans la cuisine par exemple
cette cocotte connectés ou encore ce
four intelligent qui est muni de
capteurs qui permet de monitorer la
production de molécules volatiles et de
changer ces paramètres de cuisson en
fonction et donc nous permettre de
garder un maximum de boue dans notre
steak mais aussi de pouvoir garder ses
valeurs sa valeur nutritionnelle et
j'aimerais bien en vous parlez d'une
dernière technologie qui pour l'instant
fait un peu de bruit c'est l'impression
3d des aliments vous avez ici une
machine qui est issu de notre
laboratoire qui est en train de vous
imprimez le logo du thé d'aix en
chocolat la première chose que je vais
faire cet désacraliser cette technologie
qui fait peur à tout le monde
l'impression 3d des aliments c'est le
croisement entre une imprimante
classique c'est à dire un brin qui vient
déposer de la matière de manière précise
et une pièce pose ça douille de
pâtissier c'est à dire ou mail aliments
sous forme semi liquides et cet aliment
sort par pression d'une poche à douille
si vous regarder à l'intérieur de votre
i go la plupart de vos produits
transformés sont des produits qui ont
été un moment semi liquides et qui sont
passés à travers une douille et votre
saucisse du petit boucher du coin
traditionnelle n'est autre que de
l'impression 3d de viande mais pourquoi
pourquoi cette nouvelle technologie dans
ma cuisine
alors que j'ai déjà le super mixr que
j'ai déjà le four intelligent que j'ai
déjà le frigo intelligent et bien parce
que outre la créativité culinaire que
que ce genre de technologie peut
apporter
il y à vraiment des applications
concrètes par exemple fait de pouvoir
retrouver une forme à des aliments qui
sont sous forme de poules
comme importe les astronautes ou en
porte les soldats sur le front
quelque chose de plus terre à terre les
personnes âgées à partir d'un certain
âge n'arrive plus à avaler leurs
aliments ils doivent manger des purées
tous les jours et ils finissent par
arrêter de manger et arrêter de manger
en communauté parce qu'ils ont honte de
manger à côté de personnes qui eux
peuvent manger des aliments normaux
l'impression 3d va permettre de
reconstituer un aliment est donc redonné
le goût de manger à ces personnes âgées
une autre application est de pouvoir
faire mieux accepter des nouveaux
ingrédients en leur donnant des formes
plus appétissante ou encore cela pourra
vous donner le pouvoir de réaliser des
produits transformés comme vous
retrouver dans vos supermarchés mais
chez vous et en maîtrisant la
composition c'est à dire en ajoutant pas
les les additifs que les industriels
mettent dans vos produits mais ça vous
permettra également de faire des
produits que vous ne trouvez pas dans
vos supermarchés
imaginez pouvoir faire un biscuit en
forme de diplodocus gluten free bio sans
huile de palme est pauvre en sucre pour
le goûter d'anniversaire du petit
dernier
je vous mets au défi de trouver ça dans
le commerce
ce qui nous amène à la nutrition
personnalisée un jour nous aurons c'est
donc ces imprimantes avec des cartouches
contenant des ingrédients qui nous
permette de pouvoir construire notre
aliments en fonction de nos besoins et
en fonction de nos envies
puis après on peut imaginer d'une
multitude de fonctions par exemple
pouvoir optimiser le goût d'un aliment
puisqu'on sait que sa forme va donner
des sensations gustatives différentes ou
encore pour finir
d'autres fonctionnalités comme par
exemple protéger un ingrédient au sein
d'une structure ou créer une structure
qui nous permet que cet aliment soit
mieux digérable ou encore des nouveaux
concepts alimentaires qui n'existe pas
en voit trois conclusions sur
l'impression 3d
la première c'est que c'est une
technologie très simple la deuxième
c'est qu'elle ne dénaturent jamais le
produit que l'on met dedans et la
troisième c'est qu'il ya une série
d'applications concrètes dans la vie de
tous les jours qui nous permettent
d'améliorer
pratique culinaire toute cette
prospective autour de l'alimentation du
futur nous permet aujourd'hui de dire
que l'alimentation est le nouvel
eldorado pour la technologie et il y a
aujourd'hui de nombreuses start-up qui
ont misé sur l'innovation de rupture
changer le monde et qui ont levé des
millions de dollars d'investissement
enfin ma conclusion sera que
l'alimentation du futur est en fait un
retour vers le futur
c'est à dire que les nouvelles
technologies émergentes vont nous
permettre de nous réapproprier notre
alimentation pour nous permettre de
mieux comprendre et de mieux choisir nos
aliments d'avoir un accès facilité vers
des aliments et des ingrédients de
qualité mais aussi de pouvoir changer et
améliorer nos pratiques culinaires donc
aujourd'hui j'annonce la mort de la
pizza en plastique perd son âme et je
prie pour que le replicator de star trek
ne soit qu'un fantasme de la science
fiction
merci et bon appétit